he's cute yeah he's you're cute
i think you're cute too oh wait what is
happening
it looks like there is some chemistry
cooking up in selena gomez's kitchen i
think you're cute too oh wait what is
happening cause you're talking to me or
you yep that's selena getting flirty
with chef kwame on wachi in the new
trailer for season three of her hbo max
cooking show selena and chef don't be
getting flustered on me now we're here
to cook that's our cooking show folks i
love what i'm doing right now it's
enjoying my life and i'm getting to do
things that i'm passionate about with
the people that i love so the 29 year
old singer is back but this time she's
blonde and apparently cooking her best
meals
today this would not have happened
season one this is my favorite meal i've
ever made hell yeah oh my goodness yeah
it's amazing the new season which will
start streaming october 28th features
food experts from around the world
including aisha curry aaron sanchez and
padma lakshmi i'm going to teach you how
to make a south indian brunch when it
comes to what's on the menu expect to
indulge in fun coveted safe group
recipes for game nights brunches
birthdays holidays and more
but please use your kitchenware safely
i'm not great with knives i'm just gonna
throw it out there
we've got an injury we're in season
three you gotta be a little bit okay
with knives by this point
the 29 year old singer might not be
great with knives but she definitely
knows how to prioritize giving back oh
thank you like in the first two seasons
of selena and chef season 3 will
highlight a different charity each
episode
today the series has raised 360 thousand
dollars for 23 non-profit organizations
that's gonna always be a part of my
dialogue for as long as i live i love
being a part of things selena is nothing
short of a busy lady along with season
three of selena and chef she's crushing
the game on tick-tock
nailing all the viral trends
and she's also getting a lot of praise
for her work on hulu's only murders in
the building alongside martin short and
steve martin i think we should just hit
him with the chart good
excellent so i'll take the lead on this
excuse me well i can turn on the charm
is it on now
it's just warming up izzy spoke to the
actress while she was promoting the
series about what she plans to take away
from the experience of working side by
side with two legends helena what was it
like for you to get the call to work
with these legends and what are you
walking away from uh from this
experience with i'll answer that for her
oh stop no i had i had a great time as
you can tell i could barely keep a
straight face just hanging out with them
it was so wonderful and i learned so
much being around them they're legends
in their own right but they've you know
they're good people humble funny kind
and professional and it was just the
best